avec un simple détecteurs de métaux en
juillet 2009 en anglais au chômage
trouvait un trésor dans un champ un
butin évalué à un million d'euros
une découverte comparable à celle du
tombeau de toutankhamon
de quoi en faire rêver plus d'un même
chez nous notre pays recèle de trésors
des trésors enfouis caché au fil des
siècles
hervé les recherches depuis 32 ans
aujourd'hui c'est celui de la vache d'or
une idole en or ce serait quelque part
dans cette montagne près de
fontaine-de-vaucluse des villageois
l'aurait caché
peu avant la révolution moi j'étais
parti sur l'histoire de trésor caché par
les habitants de fontaine tout ça de la
légende et là j'ai rencontré denis donc
qu'il ya une catégorie qui n'a paru très
intéressante et je pense que ce serait
plutôt de l'or qui auraient été amenés
par l'eau souterraine et qui sera déposé
dans une grotte quelques portes après 45
minutes de marche
hervé denis poète enfin se trouvait près
du but ce qui veut dire la marmite en
salaire
la vache d'or on est ici comme temps
cache quelque chose en fait il faut un
repère immuable et cette fontaine et
l'air depuis des centaines d'années
une fontaine qui pourrait être un
premier indice pour hervé rolland lui a
réalisé le rêve de tout chercheur de
trésors en 2002 ce spéléologue a
découvert plus de 1600 pièces antiques
dans ce gouffre
les visiteurs les ont jetés dans l'eau
au fil des siècles sans doute pour faire
un jeu quand on a découvert les pièces
va on a chanté on a dansé sous l'eau
voilà ça peut paraître un peu bizarre
mais c'était comme ça donc c'est les
manifestations de joie devant
l'importance on sent qu'on a découvert
quelque chose d'important
rolland n'a pas gardé une seule pièce
comme beaucoup de trésors cette
trouvaille est désormais exposée dans un
musée où il peut les contempler
l'intérêt pour nous c'est pas de les
posséder
l'intérêt pour nous c'est de les avoir
trouvés de permettre aux gens de venir
les admirer quoi le plus grand nombre
elles appartiennent à tout le monde
le plus émouvant c'est de s'imaginer que
effectivement quelqu'un a tenu cette
pièce il ya 2000 ans et l'a jeté et
fantasmé sur les raisons qui l'ont amené
à jeter cette pièce des pièces anciennes
il pourrait y en avoir dans nos jardins
des pièces on en trouve partout parce
que il en a été perdu énormément au
cours des siècles en bas monnaies depuis
800 ans avant jésus-christ
on sait comme il en a été faite parce
que les de la comptabilité a toujours
été tenue on sait combien on en a
aujourd'hui on en a 60 % et 40 % qui
nous manque
soros ans nos pieds et pourquoi pas dans
ce jardin il suffit de se munir d'un
détecteur comptait entre 150 et 800
euros suivant le modèle donc tu prends
une mode dans la main tu la passe devant
le disque et voilà c'est pas la peine
d'aller plus je jouais déjà ce que c'est
on est ok donc là c'est pas là c'est un
cetain sais pas c'était un morceau de
boîtes d'aluminium ou de pots de yaourt
et ensuite il faut boucher les trous
pour laisser l'endroit exactement
comment la trouver
hervé explique à son ami jean philippe
les règles de vastes un bon chasseur il
connaît les détails qui peuvent vous
mener sur de bonnes pistes
tenez ce puits a priori banale sauf si
vous y plonger une caméra fibroscopie tu
as tu est éclairante
et on a fait descendre ici tout
simplement pour voir tu vois la voûte là
et en fait on a dit on a détecté un vide
là dessous on a percé un mur un petit
peu plus loin en devenant repasser la
caméra à nouveau et là on s'aperçut
qu'il y avait une pièce de soul en fait
il y a un an à la demande de la
propriétaire des lieux
il a mené l enquête il a réussi à mettre
à jour un souterrain oublié on va
descendre rigueur la leçon se poursuit
donc sous terre l'oeil du chasseur fait
la différence dans ce genre d'endroit
dans ce genre de recherche
on est attentif aux européens par
exemple toi ici tu es un python qui
apparemment ne sert à rien une des
habitudes de kacha c'était en fait de
tendre un fil à plomb à ce genre d'
euros perd le fil à plomb est tombée à
l'aplomb hockey ont creusé ici et en
fait on retrouvait toujours son teaser
comme ça donc ça demande de vérifier
rien à la verticale de la marque
la propriétaire lui a parlé d'une
légende familiale concernant une
médaille cachés gaultier a donc pas
derrière moi et claire mois
éventuellement hervé ne l'a pour
l'instant pas trouvé
pourtant il connaît bien les habitudes
de nos ancêtres 1 chaque tranche d'âge à
chaque à chaque classe sociale à sa
façon de cacher une personne religieuse
va cacher plutôt en hauteur près du ciel
dans les statistiques bien sûr ensuite
un paysan va cacher plutôt sur le sol
près de la terre 1 81% les cages de
paysans se situer dans le poulailler
parce que c'est un signal d'alarmé des
animaux de la ferme donné l'alerté dès
que quelqu'un essaie de rentrer dans le
poulailler
non apparemment l'arrière hervé
reviendra il ne se décourage jamais de
même sur le territoire de la vache d'or
il ne peut s'empêcher de sonder la
source d'eau qui pourrait bien se
révéler plus qu'un repère géographique
là au centre du disque dur ici sous la
feuille de brick
je pense que cette pièce qui est très
actuel elle est certainement à l'origine
d'un voeu est donc on va la rendre à
dans cette eau de fontaines magiques
ce ne sera pas pour cette fois sachez
que si par hasard vous trouver un trésor
50% reviendra au propriétaire du terrain
le reste sera pour vous